Guten Tag, mein Name ist Jujal, ich bin der Diensabender auf dieser Station.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen, Sie sind am Ende ein Verständnis.
Gerne, sehr gerne.
Bevor wir für Ihre aktuelle Bescheid werden kommen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen für Ihre Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hamsta, Tobias Hamsta.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Hamsta?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42 Jahre alt.
Richtig.
Okay, wann sind Sie noch geboren?
Am 20. Januar 1981.
81 Jahre alt.
Genau.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
Ich bin 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Und ich bin 73 groß.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Was für Sie, Herr Hamsta, zu uns?
Ich habe seit zwei Tagen stark Schmerzen im Oberbau.
Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, seit zwei Tagen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei sie ja möchten, sind sie ja stark in Schmerzen entspricht?
Also ich habe jetzt schon Schmerzen in die Kommande genommen.
Ich habe schon bestimmt 7 oder 8 Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Jetzt aktuell würde ich sagen ungefähr bei 6.
Aber die waren sehr stark gestern vor allen Dingen gar nicht auszuhalten.
Deswegen habe ich direkt 2 Ibuprofen auf einmal eingenommen gestern Abend.
Okay, habt das Ibuprofen Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Was geholfen?
Ich habe Angst, dass die Schmerzen wieder auftreten.
Das war eine Hölle für mich.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr.
Wissen Sie, was die Schmerzen ausgelöst hat?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, deswegen bin ich hier.
Sie sollen das ja rausfinden.
Ja, ich würde gerne alles machen.
Und sind die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen,
irgendwo in anderen Regionen aus?
Nein, die Schmerzen sind eigentlich auch schwer.
Okay, sind die Schmerzen plöftig aufgetreten
oder haben Sie in der Zeit verschlechtert?
Die sind tatsächlich so langsam aufgetreten,
aber gestern war Katastrophe.
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen schon nicht Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen schon seit Donnerstagabend.
Sind die Schmerzen abhängig oder belastungsabhängig?
Ich habe auch schon seit 2 Tagen kaum etwas gegessen,
weil ich Angst habe, dass die Schmerzen kommen,
aber nicht belastungsabhängig.
Ich habe jetzt eher so ein bisschen weniger gegessen.
Ich habe ein bisschen schon kurz gegessen.
Okay, ist Ihnen überall?
Manchmal, aber nicht so stark.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Hab ich nicht gemessen.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
was die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert?
Ich bin Profil, hilft.
Okay, und sonst gibt es noch andere Akteuren?
Ich habe nur Profil gehabt, das hat geholfen.
Ganz geholfen, weil ich immer noch Schmerzen habe.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier in der Ambulanz.
Ich hoffe, dass nichts Schmerzen gibt.
Sind die Schmerzen im Adler?
Vielleicht füllen sie die Infusionen ein?
Damit die Schmerzen nicht mehr werden.
Ja, ja, können Sie,
wir sind endetestge-, preche-,
die Schmerzen aufhaltenden
oder Wolfen, direkt in der Hand.
Nein, ich kann ein bisschen aushalten.
Ja, nachdem unsere Gesche-, preche- und ihre Unterzuchung
möchte ich ein paar Diakonstische Massnahmen durschen.
Am Ende des dieses Unterzuchungen können wir Ihnen
eine neue Medikamente verabreicht.
Okay, das wäre super.
Okay.
Wir sind nicht im Adler,
sondern im Stadion.
Wir sind im Stadion.
Okay.
Habt ihr das auch schon?
Nein.
Okay.
Müssen Sie Sauerstoßen?
Nein.
Der Bauch fühlt sich aber so ein bisschen überblät an,
so etwas dicker als sonst,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Für mich aber nicht sicher.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Haut momentan blass?
Nein.
Okay.
Sie haben momentan keine Appetit?
Doch, das ist schon, aber...
Ich will nicht das.
Ich will stärkere Schmerzen haben.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewollt abgenommen
oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Immer immer schon so 73, 74 Kilogramm.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei im Wasalas oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Also alles ist okay so weit.
Habt ihr Verbeferren der Stuhlspammer?
Nein.
Habt ihr Brust oder Herzschmerzen?
oder ich befürchte, dass wir die Schmerzen so stark werden, wenn die Wirkung von ihm
pro Femn nach ist.
Also das ist wirklich die Hölle von mich gewesen gestern Abend.
Das war extrem.
Was meinen Sie die Hölle?
Die Hölle.
Also sehr stark die Schmerzen.
Hölle ist die Hölle von Paradies.
Ja, klingt gut.
Hüssten Sie, Herr Hamsta?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei...
Hüssten Sie Blutabnehmen oder so was?
Können wir das machen?
Ja, ja, wir müssen schwärzt körperliche Untersuchungen dann bei Ihnen mönchdeichspulut abnehmen
dann weiter die ökonomischen Massnahmen durchführen.
Sie sind auch, Sie sind in den guten Händen, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Aber schwärzt muss ich diese Aufnahmegesiebwäsche beenden, dann werde ich die anderen Massnahmen machen.
Ich habe morgen eine wichtige Dienstreise.
Ich muss nach Frankreich fliegen.
Kann ich fliegen oder muss ich irgendwie hier bleiben?
Ich würde schon gerne die Dienstreise antreten.
Ja, ich kann genau nichts sagen, weil um eine genaue Diagnose erstellen zu können,
müssen wir ein paar Urter suchen, die Diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Die Nachdemire ergebnisse subekumun können wir darüber sich brechen.
Aber momentan kann ich genau nichts sagen.
Aber wir endet diese Untersuchungen,
sollton sie bei uns bleiben, um eine Diagnose sucht, oder ist denn uns können.
Okay, verstanden, okay.
Okay, Herr Hamster.
Leiten Sie an wichtigste oder chronische Vorerkrankungen,
wie Bluthochturk, Gebetes, Melitös, Erhofte, Blutfette?
Ja, ich habe heute Blutfette gesagt, mein Hausarzt mir von einem halben Jahr.
Halben Jahr.
Von einem halben Jahr Blutfette, der sagt irgendwie, Trigli, irgendwas.
Ja, Triglisere, demnächst.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas einige Medikamente ein?
Ne, hat er nicht verschrieben.
Er sagt, er sollte meine Lebensgewohnheiten ändern.
Okay, haben Sie Ihre Gewohnheiten gern?
Versuch, sag ich mal, ja, ich habe versucht, mich mehr so ungesund zu ernähren.
Okay.
Vor dem diese Schimmersen aufgetreten sind,
haben Sie unangenehme, etwas Nahrungsmittel gegessen?
Ne, eigentlich nicht. Also, eigentlich nicht neues.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen, außer Erhofte, Blutfette?
Mir nicht bekommen, nein.
Okay, Sie sind schon mal operatoren.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich habe das nicht so richtig gemacht.
Ja, ja, Sie sind sehr jung.
Ja, und Sie...
Also, es kann sein, falls ich nicht auf das allergische Bedingnis,
kann das allergische Bedingnis sein?
Ja, ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit gegene Medikamente oder Nahrungsmittel bekannt?
Ne, nur gegen Hausstab und gegen Katzenhalle.
Katzenhalle und Hausstab allergischen.
Das macht das karışment also nur?
Ja, das macht nicht normal, das macht nur exantem oder eine allergische Reaktion.
Was?
Ein Schilder, das ist ein Hausschlag.
Unter exantem, beispielsweise unter exantem,
versteht man eine Hausausschlag, Hausausschlag.
Ja, das ist ein Haus, das ist ein Haus.
Wie aus der Zeit diese Allergie?
Mit Niesen und meistens Augenjucken.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, das ist mein Schmuckant.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operatoren?
Nein, nein.
War sie schon mal im Krankenhaus gewesen und dann ist sie wieder im Krankenhaus?
Ja, ich war schon mal wegen Durchfall,
weil ich mal im Krankenhaus gewesen in der Niederlanden war, wo ich im Urlaub war.
Aber sonst bin ich eigentlich sehr selten, kann man sagen.
Wann war das?
5-6 Jahren.
Aber ist das Ihr
Stil momentan regelmäßig und normal?
Ja, eigentlich schon, ich habe keine Aufrichter mehr.
Oder leiden Sie manchmal unter Obstupation, Verstopfung?
Kommt schon mal vor, aber jetzt bedrückt mich nicht so sehr.
Okay, Herr Hamster, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Gewohtheit stillen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie und wie viele Zigaretten?
Mit 18 Jahren angefangen, ich bin jetzt 42, also ungefähr 22 Jahre, 24 Jahre ungefähr.
24 Jahre ja.
Und wie viele Zigaretten täglich rauchen Sie?
Ich habe jetzt reduziert, ungefähr so 10 Stück am Tag.
Seit wann rauchen Sie 10 Stück Zigaretten?
Also seit halbis Jahr.
Aber vorher, wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie?
Eine Packung.
Okay, Herr Hamster, trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig, also ab und zu mal.
Am Wochenende, wenn Freunde da sind, oder wenn ich weg bin.
Was trinken Sie?
Bier, Cocktails, je nachdem, was da ist.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht die nächste Frage, das ist eine unangenehme Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt?
Jetzt aktuell oder schon mal gehabt?
Schon mal.
Ich habe schon mal etwas geraucht, aber jetzt aktuell nicht.
Früher, wo ich 18, 19 war, habe ich schon mal probiert.
Was haben Sie probiert?
Ist das so wichtig?
Müssen Sie das wissen unbedingt für jetzt?
Nein, nicht so wichtig.
Dann möchte ich das nicht sagen.
Okay, ja.
Also jetzt aktuell habe ich keine Drogen, aber ich habe keine.
Okay, Herr Hamster, sind Sie verheiratet?
Das bin ich.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Ist Sie gesund, Herr Hamster?
Ja, direkt bei Ihrer Mutter, aber ist gesund.
Okay, wo nun Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Alleine.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Hamster?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Immer eigentlich.
Immer immer viel Stress.
Noch viele Projekte, die fertig gemacht werden müssen.
Okay, Herr Hamster, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Weil sie sind am Leben, ja.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie an bestimmte Vorerkrankungen?
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes.
Sie nennt Tabletten gegen Zucker ein.
Dann hat sie einen Bluthochdruck.
Und soweit ich weiß, hat sie auch eine höchste Holesterinwerte.
Okay, und Ihr Vater?
Er ist auch ganz fit eigentlich.
Er hat einen starken Fall gehabt, hat sich aber ganz gut erholt.
Okay, gut gesagt.
Haben Sie Gechebis?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay, Herr Hamster, ich bin praktisch mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie schon eine Verdachtsiagnose, was Sie sagen können?
Das ist eine Marktbestimmung oder was ist das?
Das kommt darauf an, ja wir müssen ein paar Diagnose-Masthen durchführen.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe momentan keine Verdachtsiagnose.
Soll ich in ein anderes Kanken ausgehen, vielleicht?
Nein, nein, nachdem unsere Untersuchungen können wir eine Diagnose feststellen.
Okay, jetzt geht es mehr zu den Medikamenten oder was machen Sie jetzt?
Es gibt einige Möglichkeiten.
Z.B. eine Margen, die Gecher, die Könnte Essein.
Okay.
Und einige Bauchspäckchen, die wir uns finden, auch die Könnte Essein.
Wir müssen dafür einige Diagnose-Masnahmen durchführen.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Ja, jetzt, jetzt...
Wenn wir das gut sehen, oder müssten Sie dafür eine Röntgen machen?
Ja, das machen wir jetzt.
Ja, das ist eine sehr große Röntgen.
Dann bei Ihnen Bulut abnehmen, nachdem Bulut entnahme,
so weiter abkühlerung, so ultraschall,
bau ultraschall,
duschführund, gegebenen, fals, auch eine CT-Kompitör-Tomografie fernmasen.
Ja, wir können alles heute machen, weil Sie haben seit drei Jahren sehr stark geschmarsen.
Wir haben seit drei Tagen sehr stark geschmarsen.
Wir müssen eine Diagnose feststellen und zu anderen Vorerkrankungen ausschließen.
Ja, das wäre schon sehr gut. Ich würde schon gerne morgen nach Freitag reisen.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass Sie können fahren, aber vorher müssen wir die Zone zu uns gehen machen.
Soll ich jetzt hier warten oder geben Sie mir ein Raum? Was passiert jetzt?
Ich werde heute morgen nach Freitag reisen.
Was ist denn das andere Problem von Ihrem Kollegen?
Das ist eine andere Problem.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie kaum essen,
weil sie nach dem Essen Schmerzen verschwören.
Sie schmerzen auch das Essen, würde ich sagen?
Also nicht immer.
Ich hatte gestern Abend nach dem Essen Schmerzen, aber vor die Tage, seit Donnerstagabend,
ich habe auch am Freitag gegessen, ich habe am Samstag gegessen, tagsüber,
da waren die Schmerzen immer da, aber gestern Abend waren die sehr stark.
Okay, danke.
Ich bin ja sehr sicher, deswegen habe ich heute noch nicht gegessen.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie durfstischend oder bedämen Sie uns?
Stischend ist Schmerz, muss ich sagen.
Ich stelle die Schmerzen und drücke sie.
Das ist sehr schlimm für mich, gestern Abend, aber ich bin vor Verhältnacht.
Stichend ist Schmerz, danke.
Eigentlich habe ich mich gefragt.
Wie bitte?
Ein bisschen.
Ich habe es schon mal gesagt.
Das erste Mal.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, genau.
Hallo, ich bin chocolate.
Also ich bin chocolate.
Hallo ich bin chocolate.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten, ich würde gerne den Fall Ihnen vorstellen.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Tobias Hamster ist ein 42-jähriger Patient, der sich bei uns wegen seit 305 Händern sehr stärker Oberbauchschmerzen forschtelte.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit sechs von zehn auf einer Schmerzkale bewertet.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten, der sich bei uns wegen seit 305 Händern stärker Oberbauchschmerzen forschtelte.
Ich werde jetzt mal die Schmerzintensität von der Schmerzintensität beenden.
Ich werde jetzt mal die Schmerzintensität beenden.
Ich werde die Schmerzintensität beenden.
Okay.
Den Patienten zu folge, sein Innenmethodismus und eine gemalte Dispene aufgefallen, die Schmerzen...
Hat er jetzt keine Luftnot?
Ja, momentan habe ich keine Luftnot, aber wenn er etwas gegessen habe, habe ich ja Angst und auch einige Luftnot gehabt.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen seien stetschend und rückend.
Er berichtete das vor fünf Jahren eher wegen Diaret eine Therapie für die Sorge habe.
Eine konische Damenentkankung oder was ist das?
Nein, das war erstmalig.
Nach der Behandlung haben diese Probleme behandelt worden.
Was hat er gehabt?
Er hat erklärt, dass im Krankenhaus einige Infusionen bekommen.
Also nichts, nichts Konisches?
Nicht nur einmalig.
Ich mache es ruhig weiter.
Okay.
Die Behandlung ist unanfällig, aber es ist nicht so.
Er hat keine Probleme bei dem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang.
Also er hat Übelkeit?
Ja, Übelkeit, er habe.
Hat er gebrochen?
Nein, er habe keine gebrochen und keine Werte gebrochen.
Sein Appetit ist momentan normal, aber er kann nicht etwas essen und sich sich schmerzen.
Er kann nicht und will nicht?
Er will nicht, ja.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Hypercholesteronomie, aber ich habe keine Medikamente.
Hypercholesteronomie?
Ja, Hypercholesteronomie.
Hypertrigeriseridemi.
Was denn jetzt?
Momentan, seine Trigleriserid, Spiegelung sei erhöht.
Und Hypercholesteronomie?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Das wissen wir dann nicht.
Ja, erhöht.
Wir haben nur über Triglerzirurin.
Ist er etwas gemacht von gegen diese Triglerzirurin?
Nein, bisher habe ich keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Aber bei ihm sei diese Krankheit vor halben Jahren bekannt.
Er hat etwas empfohlen, was er machen soll?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber bei der Untersuchung kann ich das auch fragen.
Bei ihm ist er eine Haarallergie und Hausstabe allergie bekannt.
Er ist mit Rhinoconjuktivitis äußere.
Er ist raucher.
Er ist momentan raucher.
Er hat mit 18 Jahren Rauchen angefangen.
Er ist bisher auch ein Raucher, das sich 24 Jahre verwendet.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol, Bio- oder Cocktail,
Drogenkonsum würden verneint.
Er ist eine Frau, die gesund ist.
Er ist allein in der Wohnung.
Er ist informatisch von Beruf.
Er hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er hat viel zu tun.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Ich würde den Patienten unköpferlich untersuchen.
Ich würde das Bauchtasten abhören.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Er hat gesagt, dass er eine Triglyceridämie hat.
Wir müssen zusammen alle Fettwärten bestätigen.
Was haben Sie vergessen?
Wir müssen auch die Anfängerung des Pancreates auszuschließen.
Wir brauchen die Anfängerung.
Die Anfängerung ist wichtiger.
Es ist veraltet.
Was haben Sie vergessen?
Sie haben gefragt, ob Sie eine Nahrungsergänzungsmittel nehmen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Nahrungsergänzungsmittel nehmen.
bauen, ob er Steroide eindämmt oder wenn man es ein anderes einnimmt. Man generell.
Mussten Sie fragen. Ist ganz wichtig. Okay, herrschte.
Okay. Und Sie glauben, dass er jetzt aktuell eine
Ulkosventur sein könnte. Warum glauben Sie denn nicht, dass
seine Pankreative sein könnte? Ähm, ja, das...
Ja, ich habe je gefragt, die Schütterung, aber die Schmerzen würden nicht aus Schütterung.
Okay. Mussten Sie auch? Ja.
Ja, dafür spricht Ulkosventur Kulü.
Würden, die Schmerzen nach dem Essen verschlägt.
Ja, kann es aber auch bei Pankreatives sein?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, kann auch sein, oder?
Ja, kann auch sein.
Wie können wir eine Pankreatives feststellen jetzt?
Ja, mit einer Abdomenzoneografie können wir Pankreatives ausschließen.
Können wir ausschließen? Nein, nicht ausschließen.
Das können wir nicht ausschließen mit Ultraschall.
Wir können es bestätigen, aber was ist wichtiger? Wichtiger als die Ultraschall-Untersuchung?
Ja, die Pass-Ansüme ist auch sehr wichtiger.
Genau. Das ist das Ausschlaggebende, ne?
Wenn Sie jetzt zum Beispiel Rudolf genommen haben, oder gleich Rudolf nehmen und sehen,
wie die Lipase ist erhöht, er hat erzählt, die Triglyceridine sind erhöht, zum Beispiel,
da ist ja auch CRP-Sfläche erhöht, ne?
Und dann können, wenn das erhöht ist, dann die Lipase, die muss aber schon stark erhöht sein,
dann kann man von einer aufspeicheltrösenden Zündung ausgehen.
Wenn die Lipase in Ordnung ist, er hat die Beschwerde ja schon seit drei Tagen,
die müsste eigentlich jetzt schon erhöht sein, die Lipase.
Wenn die in Ordnung ist, dann können Sie Ihre erste Diagnose stellen,
Ultrosventriglyzium Beispiel, ne?
Okay.
Sie müssen erst die anderen Erkrankungen oder bzw. anderen Pferziaddiagnosen ausschließen.
Und sagen wir mal, der Patient hat jetzt eine erhöhte Lipase von 300.
Und erhöhte Triglyceridine.
Und er hat ein CRP.
Was würden Sie für eine Diagnose stellen?
Ja, ich würde eine Pankratitis.
Ich würde.
Genau so.
Eine, eine, die war, Herr Kollege.
Muss die schon mal sein, muss die schon mal sein.
Ich würde es auch nicht, wenn ich eine Pankratitis habe.
Wenn ich eine Scholastase habe, dann höchst du.
Ja.
Muss das eine Scholangene Pankratitis sein?
Billiere.
Ja, Billiere, eine Pankratitis.
Muss aber keine Billiere sein, ne?
Kann sein, muss nicht sein.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Also worauf ich hinaus will, ist, der kann auch durch seine Triglyceride,
seine erhöhte, ne?
Nicht Cholesterine.
Triglyceride.
Muss man immer auch eine Pankratitis mitdenken, ja?
Okay.
Das tritt nicht selten auf, es tritt oft auf.
Ja?
Und wie therapieren Sie ihn denn jetzt?
Was machen Sie an Therapie, wenn er eine Pankratitis hat?
Als therapeutischer Massnahmen würde ich den Patienten,
den Patienten nüchten bleiben.
Und Infusion Therapie, ausreichende Flüssigkeit.
Und auch Schmerz-Miteltherapie.
Und sonst Antibiotikum.
Ich stationäre Aufnahme erstmal.
Ja.
Muss ich mir sagen?
Ja, müssen wir sagen.
Er würde ich stationär aufnehmen, ein, zwei Tage auf jeden Fall,
um uns zu überwachen.
Was geben Sie, mal Schmerzmedikamente?
Ja, Nevalgin oder?
Ja, genau.
Nevalgin würdest du dann?
Und wenn Nevalgin nicht ausreicht, wenn er sagt, das hilft nicht?
Opioiden.
Ja, ganz genau.
Da geben Sie Opioiden, ne?
Pethidine oder Morphine, können Sie mal sagen.
Richtig.
Ja.
Was, wenn Sie eine Pankratitis Diagnostik haben,
welchen Laborwert müssen Sie mit abnehmen,
der nicht normalerweise Standard ist?
Oder sollten Sie machen?
Ausers SRP und Lipase.
Ja, es gibt noch ein Verb, den müssen Sie,
die sollten Sie mit abnehmen, damit Sie sehen können,
ob er eine schon starke Pankratitis hat.
Das ist Calcium.
Calcium.
Okay.
Ja.
Das Calcium ist ganz wichtig, um zu gucken,
ob es eine sehr schwere Historie Necrosis gibt, oder nicht.
Ja.
Okay.
Ist ganz wichtig.
Wenn Sie jetzt zum Beispiel eine Hypercalcium hat,
dann wird es, wenn das Calcium zu hoch ist,
ist das eine Folge eines schweren Pankratitis.
Okay?
Ja.
LDH ist auch wichtig, können Sie alles auch noch messen,
aber Sie müssten eigentlich keine Antibiotik umgeben.
Ja.
Warum, ja.
Ja, wenn die Scholastasewerte normal sind,
ja, normal sind, dann müssten Sie auch nicht irgendwie
eine ERCP machen, wenn man so los ist.
Ja.
Sondern es reicht Füßigkeitsgabe und Schmerzmedikamente
und abwarten, ob die Werte runtergehen, oder nicht.
Okay?
Okay, ja.
Sie haben ja im Ultraschall geguckt, ob es eine Steine gibt,
ob es Aufstau gibt, ob es Billier ist,
ob es Alkohol bedingt sein könnte, haben Sie gefragt?
Ja, nein, gesagt.
Würden Sie denn unbedingt bei dem ein Computer,
eine Computertomographie machen?
Unbedingt.
Ja, würde ich, ich würde gerne unbedingt
eine Computertomographie fernlassen.
Ja, ich würde auch eine machen,
um zu gucken, ob sonst irgendwas ist,
was wir nicht gesehen haben, im Ultraschall,
würde ich auch eine machen, weil bei einer sehr starken
Ankretit ist.
Ja.
Was man auch machen kann, ist natürlich diese Endosonographie.
Schon mal gehört Endosonographie?
Ja, Endosonographie, Gasplöse für die Stoeniskopie.
Ja, Endosonographie ist quasi vom,
vom Magen aus, bzw. vom...
Mehmet ist Neurologist, Herr Kollege.
Okay, ganz andere Sache.
Wie viel, ja, müssen wir den Patienten
Nahrungskarenz halten, oder?
Also laut den neuen Leitlinien, muss man das nicht mehr machen.
Nicht mehr.
Man muss, man muss keine Karenz machen,
aber man sollte ihn jetzt natürlich
langsam einen Kostaufbau machen.
Man muss nicht wie früher irgendwie drei Tage
ihn nicht zu essen geben oder so was.
Ja, man kann.
Langsam, langsam einen Kostaufbau machen.
Er darf also, wie ich ihn selber gemacht habe,
ein bisschen Schonkost machen,
aber er soll halt gucken,
dass er immer jetzt nicht irgendwie
noch ein Hinsch ist oder so was in der Art.
Aber er muss viel Füßigkeit kriegen, bekommen.
Ja.
Sollte unsere Verdachtdiagnosbeschädigung
Müssen wir Centralvenus Katheter legen,
oder für die...
Wenn das eine sehr starke Pankreativismus ist
mit 1.000, 2.000, 3.000, ja,
dann muss man ihn schon auf die
Überwachungsstation legen,
weil man ein Selbstes vorbeugen muss,
um ihm viel Volumen zu geben.
Wenn er jetzt aber nur ein 500, 300,
so was in der Art hat,
dann muss man ihn nicht unbedingt
auf eine intensiv stationale Überwachungsstation legen,
aber man sollte ihm regelmäßig natürlich
Blut abnehmen jeden Tag
um zu gucken, ob das fällt oder nicht fällt.
Es kommt immer darauf an,
wie stark ausgeprägt diese Pankreativismus ist,
wie hoch das CHP ist,
wie hoch die Hygiene als die Mehl ist.
Bei einer Eigenpankreativismus
kann man ihn auf Normalschraktion
mit Infusionstherapie behandeln.
Man muss nicht unbedingt
einen Centralvenus in Katheter legen.
Es kommt immer auf die Situation.
Dann hat er Fieber, es hat Tachrikat,
Hypoton,
es kommt auf die General- und Vitalparameter an.
Aber man sollte ihm schon
so in den ersten 24 Stunden
so 4-5 Liter Wasser geben.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
Ibuprofen,
ihr Rechimersin,
lindert.
Deswegen
Verdachtdiagnos-Pepticulcus
nicht gut, oder?
Weil Ibuprofen lindert.
Richtig, am züge.
Aber es ist eine Verdachtdiagnose,
trotzdem kann sein.
Kann ja auch einen anderen Grund haben,
einen Ulkosventil zu bekommen,
den ihr uns nicht erzählt, wissen wir nicht.
Ich denke, müssen wir nicht verdacht,
aber differenzial,
erstes,
akut infiliomiokalitänfaktab,
Kornes syndrome schreiben,
weil
40 Jahre alt und braucht
und Familien-Disposition
apoprize bei der Vater.
EKG ist auf jeden Fall standard.
EKG ist Standarddiagnostik
in der Nudaufnahme.
Es bekommt fast jeder ein EKG.
Was noch
fragen, Kollegen,
diese Unterricht ist sehr lustig.
Ich meine,
das ist
sehr schön.
Herr, das ist nicht für mich,
Murat, ich habe eine andere Frage.
Kann ich Sie fragen?